Mr Molina hey Mike
oh yes this one
hi I'm pass thank you welcome to the
class here here's your stuff okay and uh
I got a seat for you right here so come
over the last one just follow along guys
today we are going to be observing the
behavior of paneria AKA flatworks
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
possibly fast and strong
your skin is
pale white and ice cold
your eyes change color
and sometimes you speak like
like you're from a different time
you never either drink anything you
don't go out in the sunlight
how old are you
17.
how long have you been 17.
a while
I know what you are
to see it
out loud
say it
vampire
are you afraid
no
that asked me the most basic question
what do we eat
you won't hear me
alert me since when the vampires like
baseball
well it's the American Pastime
yeah
there's a thunderstorm coming it's the
only time we can play
you'll see why
I'm glad you're here we need an Umpire
she thinks we cheat I know you cheat
calm as you see him Bella okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay now I see why you need the Thunder
It's gotta be a home run right
and was very fast
you're out
come on it's just a game
[Music]
nice kitty
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
it's a necklace
I almost picked it up
this one's from Emmett
already installed it in your truck
finally a decent sound system for that
piece don't don't hate the truck
open his hand collapse
just a little something brighten your
day obviously you've been looking kind
of pale lately
paper cut
foreign
it's okay it's just a little
blood
get Jasper out of here
I'm so I'm sorry I can't
click on Jasper
I'm sure he's very upset with himself
and I doubt I'll listen to anyone but
you right now
Edward
you scared me how are you doing back up
I'm coming up
hey
look I'm I'm sorry
for what I wish I could explain but I
literally
can't
have you ever had a secret you couldn't
tell anyone
one that wasn't yours to share
that's what it's like for me
but worse
you have no idea
how tight I found
I hate this
I hate what they've done to you
I mean the Killer part is you already
know
do you remember when we walked on the
beach in La plush
the story about
the cold ones
I guess I understand why that's the only
part
[Music]
and there's gotta be something
that you can do no I'm in it for life
maybe we should just get out of here for
a while
I'll just leave
just you and me
you didn't do that
I would do it for you
Bella
I need to see him
he's not dead
I'm sorry I really need to see him Bella
[Music]
[Music]
what did you do
hey what did you do hey what did you do
with him easy he didn't want this what
did we do what did he do what did he
tell you both of you called something
damn he tells me nothing because he's
scared of you
[Laughter]
too late now let's get back oh
calm down now
[Music]
don't run
[Music]
away
[Music]
thank you
hey take Bella back to Emily's place
it's the wolf's side of the bag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop trying to take your clothes off
[Music]
not tonight
[Music]
[Music]
you don't
that's fine
believe me I want to
I just want to be married to you first
you really make me feel like I'm some
sort of like villain trying to steal
your virtue or something
oh my virtue I'm concerned about
are you kidding
it's just one rule
want to leave Unbroken
it might be too late for my soul but I
will protect yours
I know it's not a modern notion it's not
modern
ancient
different era
things were
a lot less
complicated
and if I'd met you back then I would
have
recorded you
would have taken chaperone strolls and
iced tea on the porch
I may have stolen a kiss or two
only
after asking your father's permission
I would have got down on one knee
and I would present at you with a ring
this is my mother's
Isabella Swan I promise to love you
every moment forever
when you do me the extraordinary honor
of marrying me
yes
[Music]
sleep with all that teeth chattering
going on
forget it
she may need her toes someday
let's face it
I am hotter than you
get your hand off me
keep your hands off her don't fight
it's sick it's on you
all right
wow you're freezing Bella
relax
don't warm up soon
faster if you took your clothes off
Jake survival 101
foreign
akes
it's time I spent with you
number one is when you said you marry me
Mrs Cohen
this is the 21st century I at least want
to hyphenate my name
you're marrying him
Jake
you knew he was listening
Jake stop let him don't
[Music]
Jake stop
Jake please I'm done I'm so done
what can I do you can't do anything I
can
by going out there and killing something
no you're not thinking clearly don't do
that maybe I'll get myself killed and
make it simple for you for you no just
Jake stay
why
Give Me One Good Reason
because I don't want to lose you
it's not good enough
because you're too important
still not good enough
Jacob
Jacob
kiss me
[Music]
I'm asking you
to kiss me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here on this glorious day to witness the
union of Edward Cullen and Bella Swann
please repeat after me
I Edward Cullen
take you Bella Swan
take you Bill swan
history
the series
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sure
[Music]
life is
so beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
almost every try
this doesn't work
I trust you
[Music]
I'd wait
for you
[Music]
prepare me for
privilege
[Music]
if I had always
within your touch
if I had all seen how you smile when you
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right that's enough experimenting
for one day Jacob
he's doing great yeah
let's not push it though
Dude tell her Jacob this should be good
look
it's a wolf thing what's a wolf thing
you know we have no control over it we
can't choose who it happens with and it
doesn't mean what you think Bella I
promise take one has me out of the room
oh don't touch me right now I don't want
to hurt you
oh
you imprinted on my daughter it wasn't
my choice she's a baby not like that
you think Edward would let me live if it
was still debating I've held her once
one time Jacob and already you think
that you have some moronic wolfy claim
on her
She's Mine
it's fine Leah
you're gonna stay away from her you know
I can't do that
everybody
which is amazing right
do you remember how much you wanted to
be around me three days ago that's gone
now right long gone because it was her
from the beginning it was Nessie who
wanted me there Nessie
you nicknamed my daughter after the loch
this monster
are you okay
Steph I'm sorry
you know me better than anyone
all I want is for Ness
Renesmee to be safe happy
look
nothing ever made sense before
you me any of it
and now I understand why
this was the reason
[Music]
I want to show you something
what
[Music]
the day we met I'm Edwards
[Music]
right from the start I knew that I'd
found a home for my heart
beats fast colors
foreign
[Music]
oh I still
can't say
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's one exception
[Music]
you show me again
[Music]
I've got a lot of time
forever
I have died every day waiting for you
darling don't be afraid I loved you four
thousand years
[Music]